Doodly-doo, going down the mountain! Doodly: hello! So I just spent all day recording, well not all day
But I recorded a bunch of videos today, and I've been really loving playing super flight
It's just like a very relaxing, like, so even though it's like,
*panics* horrendously
Nerve-racking with like the-the risk of death flying around every corner. I just kind of had fun with it, so I
(Markimoo noises) Wasn't paying attention I probably should look while I'm flying down a mountain
I'm trying to get a high score, but every time I get like some good moves
I try to be fancy about it and so I shoved my head up my own anoose
and then I.. I'm just an asshole about it, and then I don't go anywhere so
This is a weird one, what the hell. Oh my god. I've never seen a map like this is so cool (so cool count: 1)
wheeEE
Free points! Uh oh! Oh getting fancy. (Stroke), awesome, I know. Oh, I know it's so cool. Yeah. I think it's randomly generated (so cool count:2)
I'm not 100% sure ,honestly
It's a fun fun fun adventure.
shoop, Niicee, my high score is dismally low right now because for some reason, I can't keep a streak going to save my life
uh oh, uH OH, OHHH NO
See that happens! I get stupid!
You're a man, in like, uh, wing suit, like one of those cliff diving wing suits.
squirrel suits, or whatever they call em', I'm not 100% sure.
But yeah, its one of those suits, and you're going around and you're being an idiot
Tiny! tiNY! TINY!! nailed it. Why wasn't that a bonus? >:0
Stupid! To the window, to the wall,to the sweat drip down my foreheAD! UGHHAHAHA
I'm an idiot
OHH Double! oh come on! it's not worth double!?
its not a double dagger?!
Piece of garbage just circle back around oh now. I got the speed for it. Oh. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah
Oh, it's such a fun I almost lost it. I don't know why but I almost lost that please give me enough speed
I
Know that I can't make those and then
Okay good news good news
Have you heard the good news the good news is I'm not terribly stupid and this guy hasn't died yet. Oh my god. Oh
Okay, great great. It's not going in that portal. Just yet. We've got too much good stuff here, ooh
Way too close
uh ah
How about this one? No? I'm not gonna make that one note
I would not I I knew I wouldn't have made that one so it's good call on my part
I'm a smarty can I make anything else? No okay? All right?
See ya!
It's good. It's good. All right cool
Oh, so the way this game works is exactly like if you were wingsuiting down a mountain. You kind of just
just slam your face and break your everything, every bone in your body gets broken so that's
That's literally the only way to play so it's the only way to do it in real life, too, I guess I
Don't understand anyone that would actually do this in real life (I would hope not, but some do)
Like I get it the adrenaline rush is what people go for but personally like it's just like the risk for the reward oooooh
That is nooot anything *sighs at his inevitable crash* Oh God
See I get up to like 20 to 30,000 and then I just lose it because I play it fast and loose like an idiot (at least he's trying)
OOOOH like an
*nervous laughs at his fast and furious crash*
ooh, that did not go well for that guy
It is why i cou-  *crashes again* pfttbbbhh This is why I couldn't do it in real life
That's why I would never do in real life
Cuz I would die like just plain and simple I would just die TINY- *crashes once more* Oh god, there is no saving it
There's no second chances for me. It is just pure. Oh, I'm not gonna make that yeah
I don't even think that gap is get a bow if it is gettable
It's so precise that it's not definitely not worth trying for, but here I go again. Ah haha
I made it in the hole that means it's possible
Okay, ah
AUGH so close I just want to get this in super fun. Oh
Come on. I was right there
Uh-oh it's millimeters. It's millimeters
It's millimeters- okay on target, ye-ehe-ss
(ah finally he did it!)
Yaaas, yaaas, yaas, oh
Yes, oh oh. Yes. Oh yes. Oh yes
oooh, yes
Come on is that it, that it really?
alright, welp here we go
noowaaaaoooh
*shakes head at self* tsk
I'll never break the twenty thousand barrier because I'll always be stupid *jump cut woop* a, b, Yes always
b stupid, always b stupid
*the sound of concentration*
*the sound of concentration* - Oof
Oof x2
Oof x3
Oof x4
Oof x5 - Oof x6
ooowwwff
oof Why do I choose to do things the hard way
*panic of the opera*
*more opera*
*a sing song improvise*
Okay cuz it's more satisfying see, this is- see
I say I don't get why people do the whole adrenalin junkie thing and yet here
I am - I am pursuing the hard ones because it's more fun
So- ooh- I thought I didn't get that I thought I didn't get that I got an achievement, but I didn't get that
WHEE HOO
Okay, I see a small silhouette of a man who fitting through a hole yeah
Uh, yeah, it feels good endorphins in my brain. Uh uh trees watch out alright. Got some here
Just go for the small. Hole. I like it a small hole and you can quote me on that yes points
Yes points
Yes point
Not worth it though is not worth it alright. Let's see if we can keep up his speed ooh. This one looks fun and horrifying
Yeah, I bet I hope there's a gap through this oh good. There is it looks good
That's a good approach ooh bad approach bad. Ah
Okay, we're fine. We're fine. We're fine. Everything's fine. Oh, man. I'm sizzling. Oh yeah. Oh, yeah, this is a dead end
This is a dead end no it's not
It feels good endorphins in my brain
Hahaha new high score. Yeah, don't tell me to get I got an achievement called get a life you shut your mouth
I know exactly what I'm doing with my life, and it is taking a break by screaming at a game
and is
Supposed to be an emulation of a very death-defying sport how many people die doing this probably a lot
Yeah
Yeah, oh. Yeah. Oh, yeah, okay? Ah do I have enough speed. I probably don't here. We go anyway
Oh, No here we go
Okay all right oh boy
Why did I do that there was no reason it was just no reason
Squeeze okay odds of dying in any base-jump activity is one in two thousand three hundred and seventeen I
Guess that's not that bad. I guess it's not really odds. Is it. It's it's not really up to odds
That's probably the statistical odds, but not the the practical odds. See if if I were to try to base jump
I would die because I'm an idiot and I'm not good at that like how do you even practice? Oh, No?
Please whoa Wow I saved it. I saved it. I am amazing I am amazing. Did you guys see how amazing I was
Almost doing there hey, there's no gap
I was doing so good. I was doing so good
Why do I try why did I bother trying in life?
I don't why don't I just like let my failures be the lesson that I learned and just
Remember that I shouldn't try I mean that's obviously what this game is telling me. There's no gap there
I almost did it again, but I learned my lesson my failures have taught me well
Oh well where am I going where am I going where am I going where am I going? Oh? Oh god? Oh?
God is this what it's like to be a fighter pilot, or a bird or a flying squirrel?
Mm-hmm oh gosh, so scary all right. I'm out. I'm out. I know let's try it looks good enough. Oh
Don't freak out don't freak out. Oh my god. There's no way out. Oh my god. I found a way. Oh my god
That was amazing oh my god. I have the biggest boner right now
Okay, all right we're fine
Everything's fine. I don't know how any of that has happened, but okay
Oh, so scary. I think I peed my pants
Too tight a gap yeah, yeah ooh in all kinds of oh oh
That was too small it was too small oh boy here we go fancy maneuver. Oh
Fancy maneuver not really fancy. It's kind of gold. I caught the go down maneuver
It's just where I go down a lot a ye, okay. Let's try as
Uno, mas all right. We're going in
starting my attack run oh
Why did I do that I was doing so good I was doing so good. I survived all those amazing
Amazing maneuvers, I survived all the death-defying stunts and I like
maliciously slammed this character's head into a wall for some reason just because I like pain because I think some part of me like just
Automatically knows that I'm doing good in some aspect
And it's like you need to shut that shit down mark can remember you're not a success
So you just shut up and get back to your corner of failure a little bit
And it causes me to just do the stupidest things imaginable at any moment, and that's how I live my life
That's what happens in my life. I'm not doing it. Oh
If it wasn't obvious in this game you get points the closer you are to objects so the more death-defying your stunts are
Obviously the more points you get just like real life
Right and you can build up some sweet combos by staying real close to things oh
Why why?
Why oh geez okay? I'm starting my attack run oh?
My head *laughs*
I need to stop saying
I'm starting my attack run because I'm pretty sure that's the that's the code for the game to kill me here
We go on the attack run. What a good attack run. We've got here fellow gems oh
I'd like to think I'm just sending clones of Jim off into their death. I've started my attack run oh
God why do I keep saying it it is what's killing me. It is 100%. What's killing me? I've started my attack run. Oh?
Can I just get one please I just want one sweet sweet savory swears slavery attack run
That's all I want ass Waverly save early attack run. Yes starting my attack run. I'm sorry my attack run
I'm attacking my run my runs. I might as my shit is running right now. I've got running
All right there we go oh I almost land right into a Bowser again
So close so close so close there buddy throw him
So bloody closely Oh going for it shouldn't have gone for it
That was a lesson that I learned there that juncture I shouldn't try in life
You should just give up as soon as he possibly humanly can and then you will only experience joy at that point
And you can finally live your life without worrying about ooh the problems of society oh
I'm going for it. Oh, that's a sweet sweet nuzzle. Oh yeah, I've started my attack run
My attack run might have been an error. Oh that looks like a gap
Awesome Oh another one your ass another one. Oh mistake
You're about to see
That was intentional to show you what not to do now you're about to see some pro level
gaming
that I
Know you come for and I know you stay for and it is from a to you
That I send the love that I am showing you right
Now like a bullet through the sky. Oh oh
ah goddamn it
Yeah, yeah, you know what I'm not gonna go for those anymore
I'm just gonna go like why do I keep going for the tunnels?
I don't have to go for the tunnels you can just let go
Get a better combo get like the multiplier up and then ooh
Right, and then you get plenty of points, too
And it's not as many points obviously it's some points. It's not as many so I guess it's not as fun
Woah wind?! what that was that wind did wind blew me?
Wait can wind blow you in this game
Can anything blow you in this game? Can you get blowed in this game? Oh?
What a handy dandy feature
Is that possible?  I mean there is window and the camera does oh, okay alright. That was my fault
Alright, Imma go this way now
Oh, yeah, oh
That was right on the belly, I nuzzled that with my Tumtum. I felt my navel scrape along the ground there
pleasant sensation
if ever there was one oh
Wow everybody celebrate how great I am in your own way and make sacrifices sacrificial lamb for how crueI am?!
Alright cool cool cool. I don't ask most of my fanbase only that they make a Blood Pact no
meehh
Ever just remember
Yeah, you think back to a moment in your life when you're like okay. I have the chore
You ever think back to a moment in your life when you're just like I have the choice
Whether I'm gonna live my life as a productive member of society
or
I'm gonna live my life screaming at a video game that I could be good at
But for some reason I actively choose not to be good at it. You know you remember ever
I think everybody remembers that moment in their life when they experienced you know that that conundrum of choice
And they have to look within themselves and be like okay. I know I'm gonna be a loser yeah
I'm gonna be a loser and then
That is what you is and that's what I am and that's how I got to where I am today
So if you want to have the same level of success that I do which is none
just remember just to admit that you're a loser and
Don't do anything worth a damn in life, and then you'll be fine
Fear fear fear fear one fear two fears many fears one fears breaking all my bones of my body the other is standing naked in
front of an auditorium
So the tasteful nudes are gonna be a little strange for me. Yo whoa
Camouflage itself I didn't see the giant floating pillar anywhere who could have seen it you came out of nowhere
Alright, I gotta get a little ballsier. This is gonna take forever. Okay. Here we go after my attack run well
This is a mistake. Okay. There's no attack run to be had in there
Oh break heart whoa I almost made that one that was pretty good. Okay well
there's a Ledge there whoa Oh almost ah
Ah what the hell is happening there
I was like getting blown all over the place that can't be wind if there was wind in this game. It would like ruin
like the sense of skill oh
Oh, oh, I am very fortunate that the formation of the hill went as thusly because otherwise
No I daaaaa
Why I just want to get a good score nope not gonna do it I was tempted to do it but
Ohhh-ha-ha
I just said that I was tempted to take the dangerous route and I die
On the safe route, this is gonna be the high score run. You know why cuz I'm starting my attack fuck
Yeah, that's the stuff oh, yeah, that's the stuff when someone asks for the stuff
They're gonna point to this and they're gonna be like that that that right. There is the stuff now
I'm gonna be like oh. Yeah. Yeah, I recognize that stuff. That's good stuff
Yes that is the stuff what's going a portal go to portal for all?
All right, let's study this I see a spot
Risky, but I like it. NOOO
what's in here I wonder I wonder death ah
Okay, okay, all right. We made it. We made it. Okay. Oh where am I going where am I gonna wear my god?
Where am I going? Oh break? Okay?
I got to a triple score? Nice, portal time. Oh you, okay, I'm starting my attack run
Oh, No I said it oh, no, what's gonna happen
I'm gonna die very very likely very likely very very very likely okay. I have begun oh
Boy, this attack run is going very poorly
Or very goodly okay alright not  bad not not bad, ohhhh
Not bad no holes to go through, but you know
You know this is a gap. Oh, this is a gap this gap that goes nowhere. NOOOOOOOOOO
I coulda broke right. Oh, there's lots of gaps. Oh. Nope. I
Like how it says awesome right before I died as if I didn't know how bad I was already whoo. That's a good gap
That's good. Yeah. Oh, that's a bad gap. Whoa whoa whoa whoa come on. I was doing so Gucci
there we go there we go
And yes, okay, where is this going? I don't want to go through this one noo! this one just sucks it sucks
It sucks. It sucks. All right. You know what I'm gonna play. It safe this time all I'm gonna do is
I'm just gonna play it nice and safe. I'm gonna play it super safe i'ma play it super nice
I would just like coast be real chill about things. I'm just gonna go down to the easy gaps
I'm not gonna go for the big bonkers. I'm just gonna cruise because cruising is where it's at
Please please please oh
I'm not going for that gap as fun as that would be
Not doing it cuz dying is not nearly as fun as living
I think I missed all of the portals. That's alright. I don't need them. You know why cuz I've got you guys
Right I can always count on you guys Oh
What hell is this?
What fresh hell have I walked into this is uh?
oh
That was actually a gap who'd have thought oh. Oh I suck. I suck I suck. I don't suck
I don't suck guys guys. Did you hear the good news? I don't suck. I don't suck at all
I've got like antisuck I in fact. I blow-by-blow guys guys. I blow yes
Yes, yes, oh
Eh? Ohhh Fuck me
I'm actually concentrating. I'mma try hard on this one. Cause I'm doin good.
Doing shockingly good. No one could have ever expected this out of a little little boy out of
Cincinnati Ohio from a small town called Milford. No one could have possibly anticipated
Whoa no one could have ever surmised. No. I lost my combo okay, never mind. Okay. Bye. Oh my scores gonna be so beefy
There's gonna be a good one I can feel it guys, No. Oh my god. Are you kidding me? Are you yanking me? Aah?
I haven't seen any good opportunities to even try
To do any like sick maneuvers, which is probably why I'm surviving up until this point
I mean I've gone through a few gaps, but nothing that would equate to a sick nasty maneuver
Yeah, hold on nothing all right well off
I go to the next one nice nice nice nice sick nasty nice sick nasty
Ok bailing. Uh-huh got scared. I got scared and bailed and I'm only getting like 4,000 per level
So I don't even know if I'm actually close to my high score, which is like
But I don't think I'm actually close to my high score because I haven't been able to actually go through it. Oh
Never mind, then new high score everybody shut me up. Shove a dick in me and call me Sally. I need to shut my mouth
Okay there we go oh why am I why my?
No no no I said as I was doing it why am I going Oh?